angelo how did you get started in
filmmaking
uh well i moved to california 95 and
once i got
connected in san diego with the film
community i just picked up a final draft
box of sid fields work and i ended up
watching his video
on screenwriting and so that's where
you know i i started writing writing
treatments and and different projects
and once i started submitting them
i got some good feedback you know i got
some casting calls and i did some
auditions on some superheroes and things
that i kept writing about and i said
something was working
and then i connected with a guy named
james hergot from owned entertainment
and helped him kind of behind the scenes
on a movie called all that i need
and that's where i i kind of got the
bite it was like you know i want to
research more about how to make movies
and i just started picking up anything i
could
um one of the books i picked up was
before you shoot and it was just a great
insight of like how to buy the camera
how to
buy the mics and what you need to start
with and then
i saw an inspirational movie and it was
the kid stays in the picture by robert
evans
and i didn't know that he was behind the
scenes of like the godfather and love
story and the saints and those all the
movies that i loved you know i really
admired that and i started just
getting into it and just really kind of
focusing on what i wanted to do and
and that's how it began and one day over
lunch with uh james hergott
i was telling him the story about not
only my separation from my ex
and how i was having a hard time because
i was absent from my son and then i was
telling him about some other stories and
he goes you know that might be a great
project
and that's how i started making this
movie it was like it was my first baby
that's what i needed to do and i got
home and i wrote a treatment out
and
the rest was like you know buy a camera
start interviewing
and that's how it all started
you